So if the BRCA1 mutation is dominant, then why don't all
women with this mutation get breast cancer? Because I mean, didn't
we learn in lesson 5 that if a person heterozygous for
a dominant gene then they will in fact be affected by it?
>> That is exactly what we learned in lesson 5. And
that's not the case here because. The complex world of complex
traits, is complex. Right? Some alleles, it turns out, don't always
cause a phenotype because they're not what we call fully penetrant.
>> So you're saying if you have a
disease-causing allele, you might not actually have that disease?
>> Exactly. That's exactly what penetrance is. Penetrance
is the degree to which an allele causes
a given trait. There are lots of examples
of dominant traits that aren't actually fully penetrant.
>> How does that happen?
>> Well, it's complicated, as you can imagine. And it's
usually because there are multiple genes controlling any given trait.
And although one allele of one of those genes
could have a noticeable impact on the trait. We
may or may not see it depending on what
the alleles are for all of the other genes.
>> Well, how do we figure out what all these other alleles are?
>> Well, research. Long, laborious research. For
example, some research has shown us that the
risk for breast cancer jumps to 60% if
you have some types of these BRCA1 mutation.
So, do 60% of women who have breast cancer have this mutation?
>> That's a really good question. But, the
answer's actually no. In fact, very few women who
have breast cancer actually have these mutations. If we
look back at our original graph of breast cancer
risk where the average was 12%. Notice that a risk of 60% is way to the right of
that, and only a few women have that risk,
also implying that even fewer women have this particular
mutation, because it's not the only contributor to breast cancer. In
fact, the prevalence of BRCA1 mutations
varies in different ethnic populations of
the world. But in the United States, for the general population
the prevalence of BRCA1 mutations affects less than 1% of the population.